things you pushed for was a regime
change in Venezuela you wanted Maduro
out you advised to get on board with
Juan Guido here's what you said about
this
it's like scorpions in a bottle if
you're Nicolas Maduro how can you trust
Minister of Defense Padrino knowing he
was on the verge of negotiating an
agreement with the opposition but duros
position is not sustainable people know
his regime has failed it's gonna fall
he's still in power and now the
president is second-guessing publicly
whether he should be sitting down with
Maduro to negotiate an exit your
thoughts looking back at what you said
then and where we are now the president
by the way just second-guessed again a
few days after saying that he would sit
down with Maduro why because he's
concerned about the Venezuelan American
and Cuban American vote in Florida
that's what moves Trump on Venezuela he
did tweet out that the only reason he
would sit down is to negotiate an exit
for Maduro he shouldn't sit down with
Maduro in any case it's not something
the President of the United States would
do I said when I was still in government
the only thing to negotiate with Maduro
is what he wants for lunch on the plane
leaving Venezuela but he hasn't left
I think continued pressure on Maduro
every way we can can topple this
authoritarian regime and we need to
follow through on it the problem with
Trump's behavior here demonstrated
dramatically is that his oscillations
between being for guardo wanting to meet
with Maduro being for Guido wanting to
meet with Maduro show an inconsistency
and a vacillation that makes it very
hard for a clear policy to succeed the
idea of meeting with Maduro is of a
piece with his desire to meet with Xi
Jinping to meet with Vladimir Putin to
meet with heir to one of Turkey to meet
with Kim jong-un he loves the idea of
meeting with these strong authoritarian
figures I'm not a shrink I'm not going
to try and assess why that is but in the
case of Venezuela in particular there
no point in giving Maduro any legitimacy
at all you mentioned what you say are
failures for a number of things that the
President did and trying to do but yet
you didn't say I think in fact Prime
Minister with Netanyahu under your
leadership with President Trump we now
have the best us-israel relationship in
our history do you believe that to be
true yes I think the question is what
was the motivating factor for it and I
think in Trump's case it was it was as
I've said largely electoral I'm very
glad those decisions were made undal
itíd they were made but this is another
very good example don't mistake this for
a philosophy caroline glick
she says she's known you for 15 years
she's with Israel hayom she wrote that
he does have a philosophy and that his
strategic goal is to make America
stronger first and foremost at home she
says Bolton's conduct both during his
White House tenure and since his
departure is the behavior of a man who
was unable to accept that he was an
advisor to the president not the
president Bolton begrudged Trump's
position at the head of the table since
leaving office Bolton has dedicated
himself to undermining the president
whose only sin was failing to see the
world through John Bolton's eyes from an
Israeli perspective someone who's known
you for 15 years I think she misses a
number of key points believe me I was
perfectly aware who the decision-maker
was I never had any illusions about that
and I think that the the difference
between the Trump approach to
decision-making and other presidents is
that while every president takes
political factors into account the
political factor the principal motivator
the absolute center of trumps attention
is his re-election it's true that the
Trump administration policy on Iran is
very different from Barack Obama's but
you know for the first fourteen months
of the
of the Trump administration it wasn't
that different he said he wanted to get
out of the Iran nuclear deal but when I
joined in April of 2018 we were still in
the Iran nuclear deal now we got out one
month later I probably should have left
the administration then that was my
happiest moment probably of the whole
time we did put enormous pressure on
Iran but when it came down to it by near
the end of my tenure Trump's still
looking for that deal wanted to meet
with the ayatollahs wanted to meet with
homini wanted to meet with the Iranian
Foreign Minister and these were the
kinds of mixed signals that made it very
very difficult if not impossible to
really affect the kind of change that
was necessary in Tehran that's the kind
of thing that I think it's very
important for people to understand this
erratic behavior does undercut policy it
does make it harder to protect America
and make America secure after you left
the administration the u.s. took out
Iran's top General I supported a hundred
percent this is an area because I know a
lot of what went on before Soleimani was
taken out I'm simply not going to talk
about maybe in 15 or 20 years I can
write another book and get into some of
this that's that's part of the what I
take extremely seriously about not
revealing classified information you
said you're not going to vote for Donald
Trump
you also clarify that you're not going
to vote for Joe Biden that you're going
to write in some conservatives name in
your view who would be better on foreign
policy Joe Biden as president or Donald
Trump as president I don't think there's
any way of telling I've known Joe Biden
for a long long time and been on the
opposite side of almost every issue and
we've also crossed swords on foreign and
national security policy for a long time
and I'm not I'm not going to vote for
four-hit for him the difference between
Biden and Trump is that Biden has a view
and Trump has no view on any given day
any decision is possible and I find that
frightening I think the response to the
coronavirus demonstrates exactly the
kind of fear that I have what motivated
Trump in those early days in January and
February was he did not want to hear
anything bad about China and his friend
ji Jinping he didn't want to hear that
the disease could threaten the United
States number one and number two he
didn't want to hear that the US economy
might be imperiled by this disease
because that was the way he expected to
get reelected so the response was
herky-jerky
incoherent sporadic and not as effective
as it could have been that's what's
wrong with Donald Trump decision-making
and to see it in this kind of crisis
only gives a preview of what could
happen in an even more severe crisis so
when you've spent a career or at least
part of it fighting the obama-biden
decisions on foreign policy you worry
less about
a President Biden's decisions on foreign
policy than you do but what you said the
danger is on decision-making or lack
thereof by President Trump
I worry back than both this is a
terrible election from my perspective in
2016 where was a choice between my law
school colleague Hillary Clinton and
Trump I voted for Trump on the theory it
was a binary choice and it was better to
take a risk on Trump than to vote for
Hillary
I watched Trump for 17 months up close
and in person and I cannot in good
conscience vote for him again I'm not
saying I'm happy about this I'm not
happy about it and it's why I think the
most important thing I will do
politically between now and November
once I get the book launched is work to
keep Republican control of the Senate I
think that's absolutely critical I think
it's critical whether Trump wins or
whether by
so do you regret joining the Trump
administration no I don't go back and
second-guess my decisions I did the best
I could and given the opportunity I
would do it again I'm sure I made a lot
of mistakes I have no doubt of that
I wish I could correct them in
retrospect but I think the kind of
security for America that I advocated is
the mainstream of the Republican Party
and my disappointment is the Trump is so
far outside ambassador Bolton we
appreciate your time thanks for taking
all the tough questions No thank you
very much for having me